in terms of k where k does not equal
zero what is the y intercept of the line
tangent to the curve f of x is equal to
one over x at the point of the curve
where x is equal to k
so let's just think about what they're
asking so if i were to draw myself let
me draw some quick axes right over here
so that's my y-axis
this is my x-axis
right over here
x-axis
and the graph f of x is equal to 1 over
x would look something like this
so it looks something like this
so it kind of spikes up there and then
it comes down and then it goes like this
and i'm just doing a rough approximation
of it so it looks something like that
and on the negative side it looks
something like
something like this
so this is my hand-drawn version of
roughly what this graph looks like so
this right over here is f of x is equal
to 1 over x now we are concerning
ourselves with the point x equals k so
let's say i mean it could be anything
that's non-zero but let's just say that
this is k right over here
so that is the point k
k
1 over k
k 1 over k and we want to find the line
we can think about this we can visualize
the line tangent to the curve there so
it might look something
might look something like this
and we need to figure out its
y-intercept where does it intercept the
y-axis so we need to figure out this
point
this point right over here
well the best way to do it if we can
figure out the slope of the tangent line
here the slope of the tangent line is
just the derivative of the line at that
point if we could figure out the slope
of the tangent line we already know that
that line contains the point we already
know it contains the point this point
right over let me do this in a different
color
we know it contains the point
k comma 1 over k
so if we know its slope we know what
point it contains we can figure out we
can figure out what its y intercept is
so the first step is just well what's
the slope of the tangent line well to
figure out the slope of the tangent line
let's take the derivative
so
if we write f of x instead of writing it
as 1 over x i'll write as x to the
negative 1 power that makes it a little
bit more obvious that we're about to use
the power rule here so the derivative of
f
at any point x is going to be equal to
well it's going to be the exponent here
is negative one so negative one
times
x to the now we decrement the exponent
to the negative two power
or i could say it's negative x to the
negative two
now what we care about is the slope when
x equals k
so f prime
f prime of k
is going to be equal to
negative
k to the negative 2 power
to the negative 2 power or another way
of thinking about it this is equal to
negative 1 over k squared
negative 1
over
k squared so this right over here is the
slope of the tangent line
at that point
now let's think about let's just think
about what the equation of the tangent
line is and we could think about it in
slope intercept form so we know the
equation of a line in slope intercept
form is y is equal to m x plus b
where m is the slope and b is the
y-intercept so if we can get it in this
form then we know our answer we know
what the y-intercept is going to be it's
going to be b
so let's think about it a little bit
this equation so we could say y is equal
to our m our slope of the tangent line
when x is equal to k we just figure out
to be this business
it equals this thing right over here so
let me write that in blue negative
over
k squared
times x
times x plus b
so how do we solve for b well we know
what y is when x is equal to k and so we
can use that to solve for b
we know that y is equal to 1 over k
y is equal to 1 over k
when x is equal to k
so this is going to be equal to i want
to keep the colors consistent equal to
negative 1 that's not the same color
negative
negative 1 over k squared times k
times k
plus b
plus
b then white
plus b
now what does this simplify to
see k over k squared is the same thing
as 1 over k so this is going to be
negative 1 over k so this part all of
this
all of this simplifies to negative
1 over k
so how do we solve for b well we could
just add 1 over k to both sides we could
just add 1 over k to both sides and we
are left with
if you add 1 over k here actually let me
just do that plus 1 over k
plus 1 over k
left hand side you're left with 2 over k
2 over k and on the right hand side
you're just left with b
is equal to b
so we're done
the y y-intercept the y-intercept of the
line tangent to the curve when x equals
k
is going to be
is going to be 2 over k if we wanted the
equation of the line well we've done all
the work let's write it out it'll be
satisfying it's going to be y is equal
to
negative
1 over k squared x
x plus
plus our y intercept plus 2 over k
plus 2 over
plus 2
over
k and we're done